sur les îles grecques de la mer egée les
migrants sont arrivés plus nombreux que
d'habitude ce dimanche à la faveur d'une
météo clémente des centaines d'entre eux
ont décidé d'embarquer sur des canots
pneumatiques depuis les côtes turques
pour atteindre lesbos à bout des
habitants de l'île crient aux migrants
de rebrousser chemin
certains y ont même mis le feu dans un
centre d'accueil inoccupé de migrants de
l'onu l'afflux migratoire fait suite à
une annonce de racheter aer douanes de
laisser ces migrants rejoindre lieu pour
ankara il s'agit d'une réponse à la
passivité des européens dans le conflit
qui l'oppose au gouvernement syrien nous
abritons 3,7 millions de réfugiés
syriens dans notre pays nous ne sommes
pas capables d'accueillir une nouvelle
vague de réfugiés
nous n'avons pas voulu en arriver là
mais puisqu'ils nous ont forcées en
arriver là ils paieront le prix
d'autres migrants tentent leur chance
par voie terrestre des femmes des
enfants et des hommes venus surtout de
syrie d'afghanistan du pakistan et
d'irak et ils sont parqués dans les
points de passage de gaza recul et ips à
la côté turc athènes complètement
dépassée a décidé de bloquer sa
frontière militaires et policiers grecs
ont renforcé leurs patrouilles le long
du fleuve evros les frontières sont
protégées elles sont parfaitement
protégés
c'est un fait qu'il y à un mouvement
organisé vers la frontière
nous faisons notre travail canons à eau
gaz lacrymogènes et tirs de sommation
des esprits s'échauffent dans la zone
tampon des heurts entre migrants et
police grecque gagne en intensité
athènes dit avoir bloqué l'entrée sur
son territoire de près de dix mille
personnes en 24 heures en provenance de
turquie
lagence des réfugiés de l'onu met en
garde contre un usage excessif de la
force et appelle au calme
une situation tendue qui a poussé
l'agencé européenne de contrôle des
frontières frontex a relevé son niveau
d'alerté à élever